the Joe Rogan experience I get it I get
it
but to go after someone like you is in
my opinion so incredibly misguided yeah
and it's why I asked you to come on
because I thought it was so frustrating
and watching you carve that venison up
in front of those people what were they
screaming at you murderer
that's not true
yeah it's like saying you know it's just
it's like saying you're a thief because
you cut grass kids no it's not it's not
murder it's it's killing animals leaving
even the video that someone's walking by
and they're like they're saying they're
murderers and she's like they're
murdering people no like no they're
murdering animals they kind of laugh
well how those people are sad like a lot
of like what you're dealing with with
these animal rights activists that
they're they're so engrossed in this
struggle and it's the part of their
their daily existence and they're
they're angry and sad there's one crazy
video where this lady goes into this
restaurant and she starts yelling in
front of everybody about her friend and
there's this beautiful creature that
just wants to live and it's a chicken
she's talking about chicken and like my
friend the chicken was killed and it's
like what whoa and everybody in the
restaurant is like what the [ __ ] I've
seen these videos and like they'll storm
a restless they'll be like 50 people
they go and like occupy steak house
there's this crazy lady
[Music]
because of this establishment and
because of establishments like it she
was locked away she with him she had
nobody there for her she was crying she
was scared every single moment the
maitre d I can see smiling lips at least
I think at least I'm not busy yeah
that's true crazy town disrupt
speciesism it's unfair to those mice
she's a mouse murderer it's not food now
here they sing it together look at they
all get together with signs in regard
look at this see the way your [ __ ]
little bird snow [ __ ] up a worm you
crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] up mice throw a mouse
in the cage no snow only grain [ __ ] you
that guy's funny guys amazing so yeah
there's like you know I get that there's
there's protesting and it's like it's
it's our fundamental right to protest
and have freedom speech and have these
things but that's not so testing that's
disrupting a business yeah there's no
it's not the place for it
that's harassment look if you the best
place for something like that is really
what we just saw a video you make make a
video about your
yeah you know if you I mean if you if
they honestly think that what you're
doing is wrong like this is what
something like YouTube is for make a
video where you state your case I'll
come and talk to me and alright they'd
even come and talk to me my restaurant
with science but at least with the video
you leave the comments open and then
people debate they decide whether or not
they agree or disagree or you [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] let that snow loose watch
what she does watch what she does to
every [ __ ] bug she finds she's a
murderer she's not she's not a
vegetarian your [ __ ] chickens not a
vegetarian you know it's just not you
know people like vegetarian fed well
then you got a sick chicken because
that's not what they're supposed to eat
yeah tell my cats cats need meat you
can't be the kind of vegan diet
well you can't it's one of my bits I
have a bit about it really because of
something that I found online when
someone was angry at me when someone was
angry at me I went to her page and one
of the things that hashtag vegan cat I
went oh Jesus that was illegal and
should danger cat we'll talk about that
later I don't want to do my bit I'm
doing a comedy special soon but the the
the problem with this is that as we said
before it becomes like a contest mm-hmm
it becomes like like a battleground yeah
that's my concerns like how does this
end yeah how do we bridge the gap how do
we get people like how do they stop
[ __ ] with you I have no idea that
well they're their thing is they want us
to put a sign in our window that's
displaying that that you know we're
mistreating animals and animal lives are
there right and they say you know this
extortion if we put this sign in our
window they're gonna go away well we're
not doing anything wrong you know
nothing we're doing is illegal we're not
infringing on anyone's rights have you
talked to them out at all have you gone
outside so no we had one of our managers
go outside and there they just screamed
at her they wasn't the time I think just
murderer what about snow so you know we
we did send an email trying to we
invited in the go foraging with us and
we talked about our different ideology
ideologies and how you know they're
they're really far apart but maybe we
can come to some kind of understanding
and you know at the time they didn't
respond didn't respond for a while and
you know now I don't I don't think
you know I don't think that anything
good would come of that meeting at this
point
[Applause]